marcus in your keynote address here in
luxembourg you've made two really main
points just take us through them yeah
well they both are actually very close
to my heart and you might have felt that
i get quite passionate about this one
thing is that we really have to stop to
be tactical to be political we really
have to address fiber more strategically
rather than tiptoeing around making
arrangements we go
for a strategic solution to bring
us into an advantageous position to the
rest of the world at least not lagging
behind anymore i think the second one is
what really
gets me into temper is that we are
spend a lot of time a lot of money uh in
focusing and deploying bridging
technologies for example vectoring
right right and that's something you
want to see something done about about
that i guess
um
yeah because
i think in the end of the day
we'll come to to a situation where we
have to
pay twice you know
give you an example german government
supports the broadband initiative with
money
but in my opinion
probably for the wrong purpose rather
than taking the money
for a final solution which is fiber
they're supporting solutions like
vectoring g fast and others so just
going back to your first point where
you're talking about not falling behind
other countries particularly developing
countries i think you had a plan to
solve that to make sure we don't what i
think
in order to to catch up and to bring
um
europe to the to the front uh to the
cutting edge again i think as we
sit here in
luxembourg and discuss fiber there are
others thinking and defining standards
for 5g
in my opinion there is a smart solution
for our future if we combine
our 5g
mobile access technology with a strong
fiber access network in order to bring
us back to the top
talking about at the top are there any
countries in europe that in your mind
are already at the top how are some of
them doing well i would say probably
there are two camps um i think there is
a bit of the baltic states who got
direct together
and with a longer tradition some of the
nordics
they really
knew what they were doing they were
addressing in a far more strategic way
than the rest of the european economies
well that's very interesting marcus
thanks very much for joining us pleasure